Dan is a professor of computer science
and electrical engineering at Stanford
he leads the applied cryptography group
and co-directs the computer security lab
his re research focuses on applications
of cryptography to computer security and
his work includes crypto systems with
novel properties web security security
for mobile devices and crypto analysis
so there's no better person to be
hearing about this than Dan uh he also
knows so much about uh blockchain he's
right now teaching the class about the
blockchain and cryptocurrencies so I'm
sure you will learn a lot from him
without further Ado Dan you can kick us
off awesome thank you so much Petra um
so welcome everyone good morning good
evening looking forward to telling you
about some developments in cryptography
the next uh the next hour or so and I'm
you know happy to take questions at the
end and so you know let's uh Dive Right
In so there are actually two topics that
I wanted to talk about today one as you
can see is on postquantum uh secure
signatures and the other one is more
applications of zero knowledge proofs
okay so I hope we'll have enough time to
go through both of those but I also want
to leave time for questions at the end
so um you know um you know keep your
questions and we can have a discussion
once we go through the material okay so
uh let's let's get started and and Dive
Right In so as you know digit signatures
are a pretty important part of
cryptography right it's a very important
primitive they're used everywhere to
authenticate information they're used in
certificates they are used on the
blockchains they're used very very
widely so as you know today we have a
number of families of uh digital
signature systems for example uh we have
RSA signatures those are typically used
in uh web certificates um they're
relatively long signatures and long
public Keys around 256 bytes uh
signatures the nice thing about RS
signatures as they're very not fast to
verify which is why they're often used
in certificates so certificates are are
um you know very fast to verify we also
have signatures based on discrete log
these have these are shorter signatures
and shorter public Keys um example
schemes are called schnor and ecdsa I'm
sure many of you have heard of those and
those are very widely used in particular
they're very widely used in the
blockchain space um to authenticate
transactions to do governance uh to do
consensus and so on and so forth and
then we have BLS signatures which are
also quite short and BLS signatures have
this remarkable property that they're
aggregatable you can take many BLS
signatures and compress them into a
short digital signature that's very fast
to verify yeah so you can take a million
BLS signatures and aggregate them uh
into a single into a single signature
that's quite easy to verify they're also
very easy to uh threshold eyes so
they're easy to make it so that um you
know if you need to support like a you
know 10 out of 20 threshold it's
actually quite easy to do and as a
result of these BLS signatures are used
in ethereum in particular in ethereum
consensus and so on okay so those are
kind of the classic uh uh families of
signature systems that we have out there
I'm not going to talk about much about
these signatures uh schemes in this talk
I will say that if you want to learn
more about them uh in the in the winter
quarter where I'm teaching our
cryptography class where we go into
Infinite depth about all of these
systems and explain exactly how they
work how they used um what's good and
what's bad bad about them so this is our
cs250 cryptography class which all of
you are welcome to take now of course
the problem with these signature schemes
is that they are not secure against an
adversary that has access to a large
scale quantum computer so again I'm I'm
sure many of you have heard quantum
computers um you know are computers that
that are based on quantum physics not
classical physics and is and in fact
they're able to solve certain problems
faster that can be done by a classical
computer unfortunately one of the first
examples that we have of this is that
these quantum computers are able to
break all the signature systems that we
just described so the question of course
you might be wondering well how large of
a quantum computer do we actually need
in order to break these signature
systems so I'll mention that there have
been uh some Works trying to estimate
the size of these um of these machines
and how long it would take and I wrote
some numbers here these are this is
basically citing some recent papers on
this um you can see it takes about it
requires about 20 million cubits about
eight hours of work to break 248 bit RSA
and similarly for a 256bit elliptic
curve cryptography yeah and these are
these are just estimates um uh
interestingly there have been lots of uh
recent there's been lots of recent work
on this everybody always wants to know
well when when are we actually going to
have a quantum computer that's big
enough to attack these systems and the
answer is we don't really know yeah so
some people estimate decades some people
estimate more some people estimate less
uh so we don't really know what I'll
tell you is it's kind of interesting
that there's also Improvement in in
algorithms for example I'll mention just
a very recent Improvement that came out
this summer due to regev um that
basically shows that uh using a
different algorithm maybe it's possible
to factor RSA uh um the RSA modulus with
fewer than 20 million cubits yeah so
there's even Innovations in terms of uh
in terms of algorithms okay so the
question is what do we do about this and
the answer is that we know exactly what
to do yeah this is not a problem that um
we're kind of uh ignoring we know
exactly what to do
and the answer is we we are supposed to
be using signature schemes that are
resistant to a quantum computer yeah so
we're supposed to use these classical
signature schemes so the signature
scheme itself runs on a classical
computer not on a quantum computer but
the signature scheme is secure even if
the adversary has access to a large
scale quantum computer that's kind of
what we'd like to do and I'll even tell
you that uh the NSA actually puts out uh
guidance for uh government uh
Contracting basically for systems that
the government government buys and the
guidance says that um we're supposed to
move to to postquantum Signature systems
so signatures that are secure against
quantum computer basically the
transition is supposed to be complete by
2035 that's not a very long time that's
what that's about 12 years from now and
you know they put out this long um U uh
you know article that explains exactly
the reasoning behind this but the
transition is supposed to happen uh by
2035 at least for securing transactions
or for securing information on on the
web so this is an interesting timeline
that I wanted I wanted you to be uh to
be aware of now before we actually go go
into the problem that I wanted to talk
to you about um I wanted to just mention
uh quickly that in fact uh as again as
many of you probably know there's a nist
process for standard standardizing
postquantum cryptography so cryptography
that remains secure against an adversary
that has access to a quantum computer it
turned out that actually two of the uh
nist standard the two of the N
candidates for standardization turned
out to be insecure in fact insecure
under a classical attack yeah it just
shows how difficult it is to design new
um cryptographic systems so they went
through uh the entire process and in
fact it turned out two of the ones that
basically survived almost to the very
end turned out to be later turned out to
be insecure under a classical attack so
the question is um how do we deploy
these new systems in a way that's secure
and so I just wanted to stress that when
deploying these systems it's very
important to deploy them in what's
called a hybrid deployment where we use
both the pre-quantum system and the
postquantum system okay so in a real
world deployment what we'll have is uh
the public key will be basically uh you
know a pre-quantum public key like maybe
a schnor ecdsa BLS public key along with
the postquantum public key uh and the
signature similarly would be a pair of
signatures one issued by the pree
pre-quantum public key and one issued by
the postquantum publicy
yeah and this will ensure basically the
fact that we're using both the
pre-quantum and the postquantum public
Keys together would ensure that even if
the postquantum system turns out to be
insecure we we still have the security
of the pre-quantum system and if uh you
know in a decade or two or three or four
the adversary builds a quantum computer
then um we'll have Security based on a
PO post Quantum system okay so I do want
you to remember that it's actually quite
important to deploy these things in
tandem it's not that we're abandoning
the pre-quantum systems so schnor ecdsa
BLS all those will continue to be used
just in tandem with a a post Quantum
system okay very good so um so what has
nist standardized so basically the N
nist standard or standardizing three
postquantum signature systems yeah so
they're called a lithium Falcon and
sphinx plus yeah and I wrote down the
parameters for all three and that's kind
of wanted what I wanted to share so if
we look at the first one which is a
pre-quantum system yeah here we're
interested in the size of the the public
key plus the size of the signature yeah
I don't know if you can see my cursor
but I'm pointing to the First Column so
the size of the public key plus the size
of the signature and the second column
the column on the right basically
measures how long it takes to verify
each one of these signatures yeah so um
I'll use uh DSA or Ed DSA which is a
pre-quantum signature I'll use that as a
baseline for measuring time so we'll
call that one okay so you can see that
for Ed DSA the size of the public key in
the signature is relatively short it's
about 112 FES and verification time as I
said is one because that's our that's
our normalization normalization Factor
now when you look at lithium and Falcon
these are lattice based uh systems you
can see that the Publican signatures are
much longer than for ecdsa they're like
almost a factor of 10 order of magnitude
longer than for a DSA verification time
is faster which is cool but the length
is actually a problem and we'll talk
more about that in a minute uh the next
category are what are called hash Bas
signatures yeah and hash BAS signatur
uh you can see they're also they perform
well you know they're only about 1.7 to
two times slower than regular signatures
the problem with them is that they um
the signatures themselves are actually
quite large yeah so it's about 8
kilobytes um for Sphinx and um I wrote
down 932 for um what are called stateful
hashway signatures and finally I wanted
to mention the last category of
postquantum signatures these are
postquantum signatures based on what are
called isogenes uh again this is a paper
that just came out in 23 it's called C
sqi sign HD where the signatures are
actually not that bad you know it's 160
bytes um so getting close to the
pre-quantum levels but of course
verification time is actually quite uh
terrible you can see it's like 500 times
as long to verify these signatures so
these are problematic for but
problematic not because of the length
but because of uh the time okay so this
is kind of the state of the art state of
the world when it comes to post Quantum
signatures and what I wanted to tell you
is kind of let's look at the at the Imp
applications of using signatures with
these parameters in particular I wanted
to focus on the length of these
signatures that we see here so the N uh
St schemes that are to be standardized
you can see they're quite long and I
wanted to talk about kind of the uh the
implications of that yeah so uh you know
as we said here they're about an or
order of magnitude longer than what we
have with pre-quantum signatures what
that would mean is like for example when
you go to a website and you download uh
some web content the first thing have to
do is you have to download the
certificate from that website but it's
not only the certificate from the
website you're going to for example if
you go to the New York times.com they
will redirect you to about 20 other
websites that serve all sorts of other
components of the page like um you know
various ads various JavaScript
components uh and so on so you have to
establish about you know 20 connections
when you go to a typical website um and
add the certificates for all these
websites would be about 10 times longer
than they are today what that means is
that the uh you know the actual messages
from the server to the browser that
contains those certificates will no
longer fit in a single packet they have
to be multiple packets and that will
actually slow things down by quite a bit
so that's the implication for for web
content so it can be done and in fact
there have been experiments that show
that it that it works all right uh but
it does introduce additional cost for
blockchains the cost is actually quite
more sign significant in particular when
you look at transactions let's just take
Bitcoin transactions just as an example
in bit Bitcoin transactions most of the
data that goes into uh a transaction
actually is the signature data already
even with um you know short ecdsa
signatures even then much of the
transaction data is the digital
signature if we transition to these
postquantum signatures now transactions
become 10 times bigger and that's going
to increase the the size of the Chain by
a factor of 10 yeah so now everybody has
to store 10 times more information uh
just because signatures became a lot
bigger so the expense uh grow goes up by
quite a bit so uh you know so the fact
that these signatures are large is
problematic uh for for the web but it's
very problematic uh in the blockchain
space and so the question is what do we
do whoops I skipped on something so the
question is what do we do um yeah oh I I
should say so because of this actually
nist actually reopens the call for
proposals they actually um asked for
additional postquantum signatures by the
summer and um you know addition so you
know there's additional review for um
for postquantum signatures that's going
on right now okay um I guess uh what I I
guess before we talk about what can be
done about uh better postquantum
signatures one thing that I wanted to
mention is that um one area of of
computing that's kind of important to
move to postquantum signatures is what
we call signing software updates right
so the situation is this imagine imagine
somehow um tomorrow morning you wake up
you open the the newspaper and you read
that actually somebody built a quantum
computer that's able that's able to
break um one of these existing signature
schemes well that would mean that now an
attacker can sign Rogue software updates
and distribute them to the entire world
and they would look perfectly fine for
uh for every uh client's client's um
computer out there and so these software
Rogue software updates would be
installed everywhere so this is kind of
um you know our uh this is kind of a
critical resource basically signing
software updates something that we have
to make sure is secure and so um one so
one would like to use actually the most
reliable signature schemes that we have
for that application and what's
interesting is that for that application
because you're download downloading uh
you know relatively large software
updates it's tens of megabytes it
doesn't really matter if the signature
scheme is um 100 bytes or 10 kilobytes
it's still negligible compared to the
actual software update that you're
downloading so we'd like to use super
secure signature schemes where the size
of the signature doesn't really matter
and for that it actually makes a lot of
sense to use what are called hash based
signatures yeah so this is a bit of a
call to arms so I hope some of you
actually have a say in um how industry
actually signs software updates and I
think it's actually quite important in
the short term to move from the existing
digital signature schemes that are being
be being used for software updates to
these hash based signatures yeah there
are as far as we can tell that these are
the strongest signature schemes that we
have um they're a little bit long but it
doesn't matter this context and so this
is actually quite important uh to
transition to so hopefully um we can
convince you know with your help we can
convince industry to actually do this
move to um to uh uh yeah to uh to Hash
based signatures at least for software
updates all right so and this is
something that would be great to discuss
more in the Q&A session to see basically
how can we actually uh speed this along
all right so that's kind of the
situation with uh these um uh these sign
you know with with hasb signatures and
software updates so next I wanted to
talk about um basically you know other
types of other ways to build short and
efficient postquantum signature okay so
this is kind of the open problem that I
wanted to tell you about basically how
do we build short and efficient
postquantum signatures today the answer
is we don't know how to do it yeah
either we have um long postquantum
signatures that are efficient or we have
short postquantum signatures that are
inefficient and the question is can we
have the best of both work
all right and so what can we say about
that so there was a promising path that
uh for a while I was actually quite
excited about and we spent quite a bit
of time uh trying to use it and that's
using what's called cryptographic group
actions okay so let me tell you what a
cryptographic group action is um and
then we'll see whether that can actually
lead to short signatures or or not so
okay so here we have to do a little bit
of math so let me explain what a group
action is so let's say we have a finite
group will denoted by G yeah so we can
uh add we can multiply elements El in
this group and get sorry we can multiply
two elements in this group and get a
third element and this group is actually
acting on a finite set X so what does it
mean for a group to be acting on a set
well what is mean what it means is
there's an there's an operation it's a
binary operation called a group action
well denoted by star and you see this
group action takes a group element and
an element from the finite set and it
outputs an element from the finite set
so the group a group element acts on an
element on the finite set and it outputs
another element in the finite set now of
course it has to satisfy some properties
and so the properties are basically that
the group action is compatible with the
group operation what does that mean that
means that if I take a a set element X
and I act on it with a group element G2
and then I act on that with the group
element G1 that's the same thing as
acting on the set element X using the
product of G1 and G2 okay so you know in
some sense kind of the this is the
compatibility property that uh you know
the the group the group action basically
uh inter you know is U compatible with
the actual group operation on the group
itself okay so that's uh one property
and the other property is of course if I
act on an element x with the identity
element of the group I should get the
element X okay so that's called a group
action yeah and there are many uh group
actions actually mathematics is littered
with group actions they're like
everywhere there are lots of groups that
act on sets so the question is how is
this oops how is this useful uh for
cryptography well so we have to Define
first of all a hard problem and it turns
out the hard problem is very similar to
What's called the discrete log problem
so let me explain what the hard problem
is um on group actions yes so this is
called the group action discrete log
problem which is the following basically
I give you two elements in the set X1
and X2 yeah and your job is to find an
element G in the group such that if I
act on X1 using G I get x2 okay so basic
basically acting on X1 using the group
element G Maps us to X2 we call this the
discrete log the discrete log problem
it's a very different discrete log
problem than what we're used to for
building digital signature schemes
because now we're dealing with group
actions but you know it has kind of a
similar flavor if you think about this
to traditional discret log yeah so we
say that if the discret log problem is
hard then we say that star is a
cryptographic group action yeah if this
problem that we just defined cannot be
solved by an efficient algorithm then
we'll say this as a cryptographic group
action and it turns out we actually have
lots of examples of cryptographic group
actions uh this and capture this
captures things like isogeny group
actions and there are many others many
other examples in mathematics yeah so we
have um a whole bunch of candidates for
these cryptographic group actions okay
so why is this interesting the reason
this is interesting is that um these
group this discrete log problem seems to
be much more resistant to uh Quantum
attacks yeah in fact
um you might know that the quantum
algorithm that breaks the traditional
signature schemes is due to shore it's
called Shores algorithm it turns out
Shore's algorithm actually doesn't work
when the set X is not a group yeah if
the set X is just a set but is not
actually a group then there is no shes
algorithm does not attack these systems
the best known algorithm for attacking
such systems is um it's a subexponential
attack to cooperberg uh but the you know
the fast attack that we know of actually
does not uh does not apply to these
group uh to these group actions great so
the question is can we use them to build
short digital signatures yeah yeah so
can we use these these schemes to build
digital signatures and the answer is yes
there are actually lots of constructions
that use group actions to build short
signatures one example that's actually
very elegant is called CES sign here I
linked to the paper here it's a paper
from
2019 and it turns out the the uh public
he plus signature size is about 3
kilobytes long yeah so still quite quite
large you remember we wanted something
that's about 100 bytes long and this is
3 kilobytes so for a long time we were
wondering you know can we do better
right so you know Ed DSA is like 0.1
kilobytes like 100 bytes and here we're
stuck with three kilobytes so the
question is using group actions can we
do something that's actually better than
C sign and actually maybe as short as at
DSA and maybe hopefully as as efficient
well unfortunately like in a recent work
we showed that this is probably not
going to work you know so for a long
time we tried to do it and then um when
we saw that we couldn't we asked well
maybe there's some sort of a fundamental
block that prevents us from doing it and
the answer is yes there's something that
prevents us from doing this so this is
work joint work with um Guan is Andre it
appeared earlier this year um so what we
show is basically here um what we show
is basically that you know any of all
these discret log signatures they come
from what are called identification
protocols yeah we take an identification
protocol and we make it non interactive
and what we show is if you look at an
identification protocol in this uh
what's called the blackbox group action
model it's kind of a abstract group
action model then it must be that the
result that the amount of information
that's being exch exchanged is roughly
Lambda times Lambda time log Lambda okay
Lambda Times log Lambda well uh because
the set X has to be at least size to
Lambda what that means um oh sorry so we
have to send Lambda log lamb element in
X each element in X must be at least
Lambda bits which means that the
resulting signatures have to be of size
Lambda squared over log Lambda yeah so
they have to be unfortunately what this
means is signature size has to be
roughly Lambda squar so it's quadratic
in the security parameter yeah and if a
signature is going to be quadratic in
the security parameter in practice that
means the signature has to be over two
kilobytes yeah so that's kind of the bad
news um that we were able to prove that
you know we we're not going to achieve
100 100 by signature schemes here um
because you know effectively signatures
have to be quadratic in the security
parameter so this is a little bit of bad
news but it's good to know even if if if
if something is not going to work it's
good to know that it's not going to work
okay great so that's kind of where what
what where we are and so the current
state of affairs is that we're actually
still looking for short and efficient uh
postquantum signature schemes and I
would kind of ask for your help with
this this is I think one of my favorite
open problems like I would really uh
encourage people to think about this
it's um it's probably going to take some
dramatically new idea so some new scheme
that is going to be believed to be
secure against a quantum computer and it
needs to be as short as say ecdsa and as
it as efficient to verify yeah still an
open problem and would be wonderful if
actually one of you can can solve it um
I think this is actually quite important
it's actually really kind of holding
back the deployment of these signatures
both on the web and in the blockchain
space so this is a pretty important
problem to solve hopefully we'll see
we'll see progress on this in the next
couple of years all right so this is
kind of the first topic I wanted to tell
you about the second topic I wanted to
tell you about is um uh it has to do
more with Zer knowledge which is what we
promised in the title of this session
and so let's talk about uh using zero
knowledge to prove content authenticity
okay so this is a very cute I think it's
a very cute application of uh zero
knowledge proofs to actually uh fighting
this information okay so let's see how
this works and then uh and then I'll
open it up for questions so this is kind
of a fun application of zero knowledge I
guess the first thing I have to do is
explain to you what is a zero knowledge
proof more precisely what is a for us
what is a snark yeah so a snark is kind
of this amazing primitive it's really
quite a remarkable thing that's got
gotten very practical in the last decade
and so let's describe first of all what
is a snark and then we'll see the
application so a snark is basically a
very short proof succinct proof that a
certain statement is true for example
maybe I want to prove to you that I know
a message M such that Sha of M is equal
to zero yeah so sha 256 is a classic
hash function and I want to prove to
that I know a message M such that if you
hash M using shot 256 you get zero now a
snark would do this in a remarkable way
it will produce a proof that's very
short and that's very fast to verify now
the important to stress is imagine the
message that I know is a gigabyte long
yeah the trivial way to prove to that to
to to you that I know this message is I
could just send you the message and you
can verify for yourself that Sha of M is
equal to zero but you realize that proof
is not short it's a gigabyte of data and
second of all verifying the proof is a
lot of work you have to Hash a gigabyte
of data now and test whether the result
is zero yeah what a snark allows you to
do is prove that a hash of a gigabyte is
zero using a really short proof it's
about the proof is about a kilobyte a
kilobyte no matter how long the message
is and it's also really fast to verify
it's like you know two three
milliseconds no long no matter how long
the message is yeah so it's kind of
remarkable that snark lets you prove
these really big statements with very
short proof that are proofs that are
fast to verified now we can extend the
notion of a snark using what's called a
zase narc we can add zero knowledge to
the property and require it actually the
proof that I know such a message
reveals nothing about the message M by
the way I'll say that the hard part is
constructing a snark making it zero
knowledge usually is actually pretty
easy usually it's actually uh just a
couple more steps and the snarks become
zero knowledge okay so that's what a
snark is um there's actually a lot of
commercial interest in snarks today I
listed some of the companies that are
working in the snark space it's really
quite remarkable these are large well
funded companies that are all building
and deploying snarks um let's see the
top line is consist of companies that
are uh using snarks the second uh line
uh is examples of companies that are
actually building snark systems so Li
libraries in the third line are
companies that are building Hardware to
accelerate snarks so it's really quite a
large ecosystem uh and it's kind of
remarkable how much commercial interest
there is in building these narc systems
yeah and there are actually lots more
other companies that are uh making use
of this stuff so why is there so much
interest in this uh uh now like what
happened all of a sudden that all these
companies poed up well really um what
happened is that there's kind of a
breakthrough in the last decade there's
been kind of a breakthrough in these
snar constructions and that finally we
have snark systems where the provs are
really fast yeah so I can give you this
gigabyte message and I can construct a
proof that I know that I I know such a
gigabyte message and I can do it
relatively relatively quickly yeah this
required a whole bunch of beautiful
ideas yeah really really really
beautiful ideas um if you want to learn
more about that I can tell you that for
example um we have a a class on
blockchains that we that I teach like
I'm teaching it right now but I teach it
every fall um in a big chunk of the
class is devoted to uh how snarks are
actually uh used in blockchains and how
they work this is cs251 you're welcome
to join the class all the material is
available online you can also uh look up
the material on the course website and
see exactly what's covered so this is
one way uh to learn more about this
topic um and again what I said that the
kind of the Breakthrough is that
generating proof proof generation time
is about linear in the size of the
computation yeah so um effectively uh it
takes you know only a constant Factor
more than uh actually doing the
computation it allows you to actually
compute uh the proof as well yeah so the
constant is not a small constant but uh
the fact that it's a constant is
actually already very very exciting okay
great uh this is a Super Active research
area it's a lot of fun to work in this
space lots and lots of beautiful ideas
coming up all the time it's it's really
quite an active area I guess I mentioned
some of our works in the area but it's
really um I have to say it's a lot of
fun to work in the space and if you're
kind of if you like mathematics and
particularly working with polinomial
it's a lot of a lot of uh polinomial
algebra very very beautiful ideas about
pooms if you like um algebra and you
like to see real world applications of
that work uh this is a kind of a
fantastic uh area to work okay good so
uh what I wanted to tell you about is a
cute application of these Nar
uh for Content authenticity yeah this is
something that we presented this is
Joint work with one of my students Trish
dat was presented at real world crypto
in Japan earlier this year yeah so let
me tell you the problem the problem is
that uh there's a lot of disinformation
out there in particularly when it comes
to images and video yeah so in
particular there's lots of uh this is
such a problem that you know news
organizations constantly put up news
reports about this like here for example
is a report from the BBC that says there
are many misl Mis leading images about
the conflict in Ukraine you know
somebody posts an article with an image
claiming to be from Ukraine but then it
turns out to be from a from somewhere
completely different at a completely
different time yeah and this is such a
problem that you'll find many many many
problem many many articles about all
this um these issues that uh people post
images people write articles and include
images that are simply taken at a
different time in a different location
so the the industry is kind of aware of
this problem and to solve it uh the
industry uh proposed the standard it's
called It's called The ctpa Standard
content Provence and authenticity ctpa
and what it does is introd is introduces
a technical way in which you can verify
when a picture was taken and where it
was taken and this was actually released
last summer in a camera in a Sony camera
uh that basically includes a ctpa
component so this Sony camera
effectively has a signature key embedded
in it yeah so you can sign images um
from the camera so as you take a picture
picture with this camera the camera will
go ahead and sign those images and the
point is that uh you can see that
basically the camera adds a signature
the c2p signature that signs the image
along with the location and the time
when the image was taken and again the
point is if you embed this in an article
the browser can go ahead and check that
the metadata of the image is properly
signed so that the art the image really
was taken at the time and place that the
article is claiming it was where where
it was yeah so uh this is basically what
ctpa is about it's about how to
authenticate the origin of of images
Okay so this makes sense I hope yeah
this is kind of a very natural
application of digital signatures um
very cute and if you think about this a
little bit you see that there are
actually some security issues around
this for example what happens if
somebody's able to extract a secret key
from the digital camera and so on but in
fact there's a paper exploring the
security of ctpa but for now for this
talk uh I'm going to ignore all that
because I want to show you the
application of zero knowledge techniques
so where does zero knowledge come in the
problem is that this is actually not how
the world works yeah so in practice when
when newspapers get a photograph from a
photographer the photographs typically
are processed in some way so for example
this Sony camera that I told you about
it generates pictures that are about 30
megapixels so 30 million pixels very
very uh high definition camera what the
newspaper will do is it doesn't want to
send such a high definition picture to
to its readers so the first thing it
will do is it will resize the image to
about 1500 by a thousand yes so resizes
the image to much much lower resolution
so that the bandwidth to say this is to
save bandwidth then it will go sometimes
it will go ahead and crop the image
sometimes it will turn it into grayscale
and so on and in fact the Associated
Press has a list of like six operations
that the uh newspapers are allowed to do
to images like resizing cropping and
grayscale the problem now is that once
you do this when you send the process
photo to the laptop the laptop can no
longer verify the signature right to
verify a signature you need to have the
original image because that the
signature was on the original image so
now by doing this post-processing the
laptop can no longer verify the embedded
signature and so the question is what to
do and that's where zero knowledge comes
in yeah so here's a cute proof using a
zero knowledge proof and um so cute
application of zero knowledge proofs and
so the idea is that if instead of
embedding uh a signature in the process
photo we're going to embed a proof in
the process photo and now what are we
proving the statement that we're proving
is you know the newspaper is proving so
sorry here the laptop actually receives
the edited image and the operations that
were applied to the image what the
newspaper is proving is I know an
original image and I know a signature
right that's what the newspaper is
proving such that the signature is a
valid CPA signature on the original
image the edit image is the result of
applying you know cropping and rescaling
to the original image and a metadata in
the edit image is the same as the
metadata in the original image okay so
those are the three statements that the
snark proof is proving and now the
laptop will just verify this proof and
if the proof is valid it will show the
metadata to the user so the user can
verify where and when the image was
taken okay so I hope this is clear yeah
so the snark statement here is very
specific right the laptop has the edited
image in these operations and the snark
proof is basically proving these three
statements here that I just wrote here
okay so that's the idea and it turns out
this works out really quite well yeah
the proof size is succinct it turns out
it's less than a kilobyte yeah so it's
quite easy to attach this to the edited
image verifying these proofs is quite
easy in the browser it takes about two
milliseconds yeah so you can just verify
the browser can easily verify that the
proof is generated correctly the proof
is valid and the question is how long
does it take to generate such a proof
yeah so the newspaper has to do these
proofs one uh one proof per image so
again it turns out that these images are
actually quite large they're like 6,000
by 4,000 pixels and you want to resize
crop and maybe grayscale them it turns
out that with enough Hardware you can
actually generate these proofs in just a
couple of minutes yeah so you know if
the article contains like uh one or two
is it would take the newspapers a few
minutes of processing and it can
generate proofs and then it can send
those proofs to everybody in the world
to every customer in the world every
client in the world and every client
will verify the proof yeah so that's
kind of the idea uh behind this it's
kind of a cute application of uh snarks
of particular ZK snarks um that allows
you to to prove that you know a name a
signature on a processed image okay so
oh I should and I should mention you
know uh people also want to apply this
to videos and so actually now we're
working on generalizing this Beyond
images uh to videos but I'll tell you
that even for images this was actually
quite difficult in that uh the image
size as I said is quite large these are
30 million pixel images each pixel is
about three bytes right for red you know
RGB red green blue so each pixel is
about three uh three bytes and so these
images are about 120 megabytes um and so
when you need to generate this signature
when you when you need to generate this
proof the first thing you have to do is
prove that you have a valid signature on
the original image it's so it turns out
to do that you have to Hash the original
image and hashing 120 megabytes inside
of a zero knowledge proof turns out to
be quite difficult yeah this takes
actually too long to do using shter 56
we this wouldn't work if we had to Hash
uh 120 megabytes inside of a zero
knowledge proof and so what we did is we
kind of developed a new way to do this
uh we use what are called lattice hashes
which are very efficient and very
friendly to zero knowledge proofs these
um lattice hashes will hash the 120
megabytes to about 32 kilobytes yeah so
they compress by quite a lot and they do
that quite efficiently and then finally
we take the 32 kilobytes and compress
that down to 256 bits using a hash
function called Poseidon yeah and so
it's kind of a two-level hashing scheme
and that's what made it possible to uh
to get this system to work so that the
proven time is uh is reasonable all
right so I just kind of wanted to show
you kind of one idea that uh it took to
make this work for videos the problem is
much harder because videos are not
measured in hundreds of megabytes
they're measured in gigabytes and so the
problem is actually even more difficult
and actually that's something that we're
working on uh right now okay so I think
this brings us to the end of this talk
so I'll say that uh you know this is an
amazing time to be working in
cryptography um so many many new ideas
coming up with these snarks with these
postquantum systems uh there's lots of
open problems to work on lots of ideas
uh to to explore so you know we're
having a blast that's a really fun area
and I encourage all of you to kind of
learn more about cryptography and as I
said if you want to learn more there's a
bunch of courses uh that I and we teach
so you're welcome to take any of those
um as I said there even in the area of
snarks there are lot there's a lot more
to work on for example building fast
approvers with lower memory Footprints
uh we'd like to get shorter proofs we'd
like to make them Quantum resistant we'd
like to get rid of trusted setup we'd
like to have a to be able to to do
proofs on what are called distributed
Witnesses when the witness is
distributed distributed across multiple
parties um and so on so there's still
lots and lots of work to do on these
snarks and that's in the that's um kind
of working under the hood in designing
snarks and then there's a lot more work
to do in designing new applications for
snarks and for ZK snarks and that we see
a lot in the blockchain space um lots of
new applications for snarks and actually
what we're looking for is kind of more
applications for snarks even outside of
the blockchain space yeah the example I
showed you here for image authenticity
is an example of an application outside
of the blockchain space and it would be
wonderful to see more examples like that
so I encourage you to kind of look for
more applications and those are always
very welcome and exciting to kind of
read about okay so I think I hope this
was clear uh hopefully I didn't go too
fast and so I think I will stop here and
yeah happy to take any questions if
there are any so thank you all very much
great thank you so much Dan and so much
is going on like your La must be super
busy at this time with doing all this
work uh we got a lot of questions we
will try to get to as many as we can we
probably won't get to all of you uh but
we will try to get as many as we can so
maybe done the first questions were uh
more about kind of the postquantum
cryptography and about the timelines and
and people are asking about kind of your
idea on like when we will get quantum
computer and also like how does it align
with trying to uh solve uh solve all of
these questions and why it's important
to work on them right now if we are kind
of still a little bit ahead oh yeah yeah
for sure for sure yeah so I guess the
first question which everybody asks is
when are we going to have large enough
quantum computers that will actually
threaten the crypto that we have today
you know uh the answer is that we we
really don't know right uh you will get
different answers from different people
uh one thing I can say is um up until
these recent algorithmic improvements
you know the number of cubits looked
like we would need around 10 to 20
million cubits to do to carry out the
computation and so just trying to use
More's law to estimate how long would it
take to get to 10 to 20 million cubits
today we around we are at around 100 two
or 200 um so you know assuming doubling
every 18 months you know you get about
you know 20 to 25 years or so so that's
one way to do to do the estimates but
then you know the algorithms are getting
better so maybe fewer cubits are needed
um and maybe there'll be improvements
that speed things up faster than than
mors law so the answer is we don't
really know yeah we we just we just
don't know um and so the question is you
know what should we be doing today um
and here I have to separate this
question uh for the difference between
encryption and signatures for encryption
you know things that you encrypt today
you would like them to be secure for
like 50 years yes so even if somebody
records your Cipher text today you'd
like that in 50 years they would still
not be able to decrypt them well if
somebody records your Cipher Tex today
and in 50 years they have a quantum
computer then of course they'll be able
to decrypt yeah and so things that we're
encrypting today might become insecure
once we have quantum computers and so
for the purpose of encryption it's
actually kind of important to try and
move to postquantum encryption as as
quickly as possible so that we maintain
confidentiality um forever um so that's
the in the area of encryption in the
area of signatures or more generally uh
you know content authenticity you know
there we have a bit more time yeah so um
uh there you know uh in some sense you
know when we once we know that quantum
computers are coming so you know maybe
um maybe a few years before as or as as
they start to scale and a few years
before they become large enough you can
imagine transitioning to these these new
systems and um you know and and Security
will be will will be restored as I
mentioned the timeline for NSA is 2035
so they're actually quite aggressive in
trying to get people to move U so that's
their their recommendation and you know
I see no reason not to abide by what
they're by what they're saying um yeah
and so lots of
activity U as I said we still need
better postquantum secure signatures we
need short and fast postquantum secure
signatures uh this is stuff that that
I'm super interested in I hope uh you
guys would be interested in working on
that and so more ideas are needed yeah
so maybe I'll leave it at that it's a
great question thank you and that was
actually another question about you know
H how how to develop these or how to
accelerate it so like how can people on
this call kind of try to think about
this idea are there some approaches that
you find like especially promising like
what they could be thinking about uh
like how to accelerate this and just to
clarify the creation of hedge based
signatures for signing sofware updates
yeah yeah yeah so right now we have
these these three categories right we
have these hash Bas signatures we have
uh lattice coding based signatures and
we have isogen uh or group action based
signatures I think it'd be great to find
more why are we stuck with those three
right it'd be great to find more
categories of signatures so you know I
would encourage you to think to think
broadly like maybe there are other
problems there are hard for a quantum
computer that we can then use to build
cryptography off of yeah you know there
it reminds me that there's a there's a
really wonderful website it's called the
quantum algorithm Zoo you can go check
it out it's a kind of a fun website it
shows all the algorithms that we know uh
all the quantum algorithms that we have
for various problems and then there's
lots of open problems right problems for
which we don't have Quantum algorithms
um and so many maybe one of those
problems for which we don't have a good
Quantum algorithm maybe one of those
problems we can we can use to build
these good digital signatures so in
cryptography we like hard problems right
we like problems that we don't know how
to solve because we can use them to
build crypto systems so you know you
know maybe go out look for problems that
are hard to solve on a quantum computer
at least problems that we don't have
good algorithms for and then try to see
whether we can use them to build these
short and efficient signatures that that
would be one way go to go about this
which would be really exciting so um
looking forward to what you find out
what you
discover a followup question uh it seems
that a lot of the solutions are kind of
like software based uh is there any kind
of Hardware based solution or like are
there some ways of thinking about it
from kind of the hardware perspective
you mean for uh this is with respect to
the first part of the talk or the second
uh for encryption uh and for the first
part of the talk oh I see I see yeah
look I mean Hardware based uh systems um
are um you know I guess this would be
this would go under the name of Hardware
enclaves yeah so those are used for more
sophis exed operations right so for what
we discussed just digital signatures no
you have to these are these would be
pure software Solutions if you need to
do more complicated things like
Computing on encrypted data then um you
know there are maybe this is when you
would start looking at Hardware enclaves
and and what can be done with Hardware
but uh yeah right now uh for digital
signatures we are primarily interested
in software-based Solutions yes so we're
interested in algorithms not Hardware
yeah it's a good it's a good
question great thank you um you covered
a lot of uh topics in the modern kind of
cryptography like what are you the most
excited about like if you had to pick
one to kind of spend your next five
years on what would would it be well
look I mean I I there is a lot going on
in the world of cryptography yeah so I
personally really like the area of
snarks just because there's so much
activity and there's so much to do but
there's lots of other things going on in
the world of cryptography maybe I'll
mention one thing that's really exciting
which is fully homomorphic encryption
yeah Computing on encrypted data that's
like something that we covered I think
in in an earlier webinar um uh yeah so
there's a lot of commercial interest in
this there's a wonderful company called
Zama that's trying to commercialize uh
fully homomorphic encryption fhe um one
of their par one of their cool
applications is for example uh running
machine learning algorithms on encrypted
data it's kind of amazing right this is
stuff that it sounds like science
fiction I can give you an encrypted
image and you run a machine learning
algorithm on the encrypted image and you
get a an encrypted classification which
you send back to me and I can decrypt
yeah and now learn the classification so
I basically got you to run your Secret
model on my secret data I get the answer
and you learn nothing about my my image
it sounds amazing it sounds that this
this is like stuff that um we couldn't
do before and now we can do it with very
little very little communication using
these tools from Zama so that FH is a
very exciting area in in cryptography
I'll mention another area which is um
called Oram which is basically stands
for oblivious Ram you know how do we how
do we read data from a database without
revealing uh the access pattern to the
database so without revealing to the
database or revealing to memory um what
elements in the memory we actually
touched yeah and so uh there's a lot of
activity in the oblivious Ram spaces
applications for it in the blockchain
area uh for privacy applications and so
on so uh yeah you know what can I tell
you and I can go on and on and on
there's like so many new developments in
in in cryptography maybe I'll mention
one more result which I which I really
love this is a paper uh from Henry
Corgan Gibbs and his group uh in the
last year uh it's called tipto which is
basically showing how to run um search
like Google search on on encrypted
queries yes so I can send an encrypted
query to Google they can run a search on
this encrypted query send me back the
encrypted results and I get the results
in the clear and they learn nothing
about my query it's again things that we
we thought are not possible are all all
of a sudden becoming possible thanks to
these new ideas so this is like a really
fun time in cryptography there's like
endless endless new problems to work on
and that's a really exciting
field great thank you uh there were also
follow-up questions about kind of
postquantum signatures and blockchain
and like how blockchain kind of it
intervenes with this whole thing so so
like could you tell us a little bit more
about it there were bunch of questions
kind of related to different aspects of
that oh yeah yeah yeah so yeah this is I
guess this question is basically how
would the blockchain trans transition to
the world of postquantum signatures yeah
and I I have to say that uh that is
easily an hourong presentation yeah it's
it's a fairly detailed topic maybe to
keep it uh just to keep it short I'll
I'll say that um you know today if you
hold let's say you hold um funds in in
ethereum yeah uh so today in ethereum
you know you you sign using whatever
traditional traditional ethereum
signatures for example would be some
discrete log based signature scheme um
if you see that you know in two three
four five years you suspect that a large
enough quantum computer will be
available you know maybe you know in 20
years you'll start you start to get
nervous about these quantum computers
what you would leave what you would like
to do then is generate a new public key
for yourself that is postquantum secure
and then transition all your funds from
the pre-quantum address to the
postquantum address right that would be
a transaction that you deploy and just
move the funds so now the funds are
secured using a postquantum signature
scheme what's interesting is in ethereum
uh you know with the deployment of
account abstraction you can actually
specify whichever signature scheme you
want in the account abstractions uh
Paradigm right and so transitioning a
signature transitioning your your your
address from a pre-quantum to a
postquantum signat
actually doesn't require any changes to
ethereum you can just Implement that
using using account obstruction and that
would work quite well so it would
require everyone to actively move their
funds but that's you know not not out of
the question and people are of course
incentivized to do that um and so that's
uh that's one way to do it there I can
say that there's lots of other ideas for
how to do the transition in fact you can
generate um public keys today that are
future proof that will be secure against
the quum computer later on but maybe uh
this is taking us a bit too far a field
so why don't I leave it I'll leave it at
that and it's a good idea for a future
webinar maybe we can talk about how
blockchains can transition to
postquantum signatures it's a good very
good question sounds great it sounds
great uh let's do that um couple more
questions and I think we will be
wrapping up afterward so one of them is
about zero knowledge proofs and how they
are enhancing security and privacy in
digital interactions and also are there
any other privacy preserving
Technologies uh outside of the zero
knowledge proofs oh my God yes yes there
are many many privacy Technologies um
yeah let's start with the first part
part of the question so you're asking
how does Z knowledge proofs help with uh
uh providing privacy yeah um so I'll
give the I'll give an example in the
blockchain space which is kind of the
classic example uh which is if you want
to if you want so let's see so today
with blockchains of course you know
blockchains are transparent
which means that all transactions are
available in the clear yeah so if you
can look at the blockchain and see
exactly who is transacting with with
with who um exactly what's running and
so on um now that has a lot of benefits
but it also has some drawbacks so just
to give an example like if a company
wants to pay their employees uh using
using uh cryptocurrency those would be
transactions that are are recorded on
the blockchain and the whole world will
be able to see those transactions so
really if a company pays its employees
using a crypto Cy everybody will know
what the employees salaries are which is
a bit of a problem because it means that
basically companies cannot use
cryptocurrencies to play to pay salaries
similarly in Supply chains you know if
company a pays Company B uh using a
cryptocurrency everybody will know how
much exactly their uh the companies are
paying one another and that's something
that often companies don't want to
support don't want to reveal and so um
there is a definitely a need for uh
blockchains that provide some privacy
yeah so the whole world can't see all
the transactions but then if you have a
private blockchains by the way a private
blockchain doesn't mean absolute privacy
you could still have privacy for example
from the whole world but not from uh you
know the operator of an operator itself
so there are many different levels of
privacy um and and so if you if you do
have a private blockchain the question
is how do we verify that all the
transactions on the Chain are valid if I
can't see the transaction transactions
how do I know that the chain is
operating correctly and that's where
where zero knowledge proofs come in
right so what we can do is we can post
encrypted transactions to the chain and
then next to every encrypted transaction
we write a zero knowledge proof saying
that the transaction is valid so no
money was created no money was lost um
the transaction was properly authorized
by the sender the transaction was
properly received by the recipient and
so on and so forth right so um so zero
knowledge proofs can allow us to what
what to do what we call a private uh
private transactions on top top of a
public blockchain everyone can verify
that the chain is progressing correctly
um but the transaction data itself is is
hidden now interestingly by the way
there are lots of proposals for how to
reconcile this with uh Regulatory
Compliance um you know in the US there
are many regulatory requirements on all
transactions uh and so it's very
interesting that the zero knowledge
proof can also provide a proof that
regulations were met for example if
there's some reporting requirements you
know as know proof can prove that the
reporting requirements were met and so
on so it's even a way these Zer know
proofs are even a way to build
compliance private blockchains yeah so
they're going to play quite an important
role you know again if businesses are
going to use these blockchains there has
to be some level of privacy provided and
the easiest way to do that is uh you
know sorry privacy with compliance and
the easiest way to do that is through
the use of these Z knowledge proofs this
is why there's so much demand and
emphasis for this field and that's why
progressed so much in the last in the
last decade yeah again it's a very good
very big topic and and a very good
question perfect thank you Dan just to
wrap us up um as always people are
asking for additional resources like how
to learn more any book recommendations
any blog posts any podcast anything you
have like you could share they they are
interested to know oh yeah yeah you know
that's a great Point actually I guess
maybe I'll add the slide to the end of
this presentation with a bunch of uh you
know where to learn more I should have I
should have done that so I'll I guess
when we post the slides we'll add we'll
include a link to more resources I'll
say if you are eager to get started um
one place to start is you can just go to
uh to my blockchain class cs251
stanford.edu all the material is
available online and in the lectures
there are there are lots of links to
supplementary material so if you look at
the syllabus you'll find lots of links
links the supplementary material and
that that that maybe is a good way maybe
a good way to start um but I'll also
post uh you know I'll also post uh the
uh you know more resources in in the
slides if you want to learn more about
cryptography well uh what can I say I'll
shamelessly plug my own book if you go
to Crypt book. us uh this is a book
about cryptography it's a graduates book
in applied cryptography it's freely
available you can download the PDF and
um you know please send me any comments
I I take all the comments very seriously
and and address all of them so you're
also very very that's another great way
to learn about what's happening in the
world of
cryptography perfect thank you Dan and I
posted these in the chat so hopefully on
your platform we should show up uh thank
you so much Dan for taking the time for
this webinar thank you everybody who had
a chance to join us I hope you had a
great start of the week uh that's the R
thank you yeah thank you you all this
was a lot of fun and have a good
week